boaz is with us in wichita kansas hey
boaz what's up
hey dave how are you great man how can
we help
hey um i i'm currently a college student
um here in wichita and i
am kind of wondering i have about twenty
two thousand dollars in savings
and about uh two thousand dollars on my
debit card
um i'm kind of afraid because right now
i hear with all the new money being
printed
that inflation is going to hit it so i'm
wondering
since i'm currently a college student
what did you hear about summit in them
what did you hear oh i
i i was hearing that there was like
going to be a lot of inflation maybe
here
coming since they printed off a lot of
money who told you that
oh man well that's that's no that's what
i've been hearing from a couple people
so i'd like to your drinking buddy in
college
uh no just a little bit on uh youtube
and things like that oh
you went down the rabbit hole of
conspiracy theory crap that's what i
thought you've been playing on the
internet
getting financial advice oh dave
what year are you in uh boaz um
right now i will be becoming a sophomore
over at wichita state okay cool what's
your question man how can we help
i'm wondering if i should go and either
use that money towards
uh my college um
but currently i'll be working so i'm
wondering should i just use my money in
my savings should i just invest that
and you're saying you want to invest
because you're scared that you may
have some inflation uh issues coming up
down the road right
yeah like my my interest won't like and
my savings account won't keep up with
the inflation rate which it's not
currently
so i'm wondering if that's a smart idea
let's stick it into investments pretty
much
so let me ask you this question let's
say if you did do that let's just say i
said yep do that how are you going to
pay for college
um student five or loans
grand in there and then the rest i was
just gonna work
while i was in college so here's my
thing no don't invest nothing
um you have the twenty two thousand
dollars in 2k in your savings account
the best investment you can make into
yourself is right now it's not
into you know investing it so you can
save on inflation no
you want to make sure that you graduate
debt-free now once you graduate
debt-free and if there is
some level of inflation then let's worry
about it then
but the key thing is i want you to
graduate 100 debt free
um and so keep that money in your
savings use it to pay for all of your
cash
get off of youtube or only get on
youtube to listen to the dave ramsey
show
the way dave is looking at me right now
you may want to come watch my show first
then go come and look at dave
because dave really wants to talk to you
right now but i'm just trying i'm
stepping in for
for uncle dave and i'm your nephew so uh
so
uh what are you studying um i'm studying
aerospace engineering
good for you good for you so here's the
point
a guy like you that even know has enough
good
common sense to even ask this question
is so far ahead of the game studying
aerospace engineer
that you investing in you what anthony's
telling you to get that degree debt-free
is worth a lot more than any investment
that you could possibly make
no mutual fund will keep up with what
you're going to be worth because you are
getting an aerospace degree
follow me mathematically yes sir
mathematically
you are more valuable it's not that's
not some kind of
existential thing of we think boaz is
awesome although we do
but this is more like dude the money
that you can make with that degree
is greater than the money you will make
on a mutual fund
get that degree get it debt-free
anthony's advice is exactly correct
okay now let's step back for a second
though just for the fun of it and have
that inflation discussion okay
just to uh just to soothe your fears yes
there's going to be some inflation we're
already seeing it
and what inflation is is an increase in
costs
the cost you have to worry about
increasing is college
you don't have to worry about the cost
of milk over the next three years
ruining your life you do have to worry
about the cost of milk or gasoline
or whatever other components of
inflation that there are ruining your
life
over 50 years but not over four years or
three years or two years while you're in
college it's the long term drip that
where inflation kills you
the only way that inflation will kill
you in two years is if we had hyper
inflation which we have never had in the
united states
and hyperinflation is where all goods
and services
triple in one year or quadruple in one
year
so a 200 000 house becomes an 800 000
house a gallon of gas is going for 14
and a loaf of bread is 10
and if you saw that then your fears
would have come true but that would be
the first time in the history of the
united states
by the way there's only two instances
that we can find in modern in the modern
world economy
that that has actually occurred one was
in pre-nazi germany and the other is
good old south america argentina
okay and so we saw collapses of the
entire economy as a result new
governments rose up
and all currency was disbanded and they
started over
this is how hitler came to power by the
way it was not on his charisma
it was an economic collapse and he
stepped into the vacuum and made himself
the hero of resetting it
and it was from hyper inflation so you
can go back study that by the way
but it's an interesting discussion the
point being is it's not going you know
if we have a five or a ten
if we normally have a four percent
inflation rate if if it's
seven percent which is probably going to
be because we're seeing cars go up in
value
houses go up in value two befores are
going up plywood's going up
you know resin you name it copper steel
everything's gone up because of the
shortage because there's
you know factories were shut down now
they're coming back after cover trying
to catch up on the supply demand curve
and we've got an artificial inflation
rate kicking up but it is a short-term
thing dude and it's not going to kill
you
with your aerospace degree you're going
to be just fine